we're coming too
for sure the lecture series was
established by 30 cities and her
daughter Laurie in memory of their son
Albert for the student here at Columbia
Law School
Robert was a very time for the person
committed to social justice and this
lecture with a focus on ethics and
social policy the special focus on
religion and this year would like to
have you know still Terman from the
International Crisis Group has studied
the Middle East for many years through
the Human Rights Watch I went to a young
project there for 10 years but ten years
and previously to situation now as chief
operating officer he was the least one
on Iraq and America's role in the
conflict with the Curtis and Massacre
and another on the father labor union
women's movements there is really what's
missing in the New York of the ebooks
Financial Times national interest
and today he will talk to us about the
mission of thank you thank you very much
Nicholas in case you wonder how he
settled on me as a speaker it's very
easy it's nepotism we're old friends and
his wife and I used to work our
colleagues in the same organization and
I have know Nicholas now for probably 20
years or so so it's very pleased to see
him after actually a number of years
because I've been outside the country
and and to be to be able to give this
presentation to you and I hope it will
help enlighten you a little bit and I
hope it's not too basic I'm going to
have to say some basic things and then
tell you a little bit about our
experience in the Middle East witnessing
these these past events and trying to
interpret what has happened and
especially with regard to to the
phenomenon of sectarianism just first
want to say to the extent that you don't
know the organisation that I've been
working for for the last 10 years the
International Crisis Group
it's an non-governmental organisation
not-for-profit worldwide active in areas
of armed conflict it's a conflict
prevention organization so but we do
research mostly and write reports mostly
that's our way of proof trying to
prevent conflict it's a it's a limited
attempt but but it's one that is has
been proven to be needed because what
what our founders discovered was is that
in areas of armed conflict there is a
dearth of independent information and
analysis usually there's intelligence
agencies that are feeding into their
respective governments but there are no
independent actors that can do sustained
analysis about the drivers of conflict
and how conflicts evolve and how they
can be brought to an end or how they can
be prevented or how
post-war situation can be prevented from
sliding back into active armed conflict
so that that's our work and and our
value added because any number of
organizations institutions can write
intelligently about conflict and how it
should be ended but our value added is
that we are based in the field on the
ground in areas of armed conflict
they'll talk to all actors the full
spectrum of actors in a conflict without
any particular bias toward any one of
them so in other words we take all views
seriously and see them as as legitimate
and we represent them in our analysis
fairly even if we end up diverging in
terms of our recommendations as to where
a conflict should go so that's that's
that's our work so in that as part of
that work I was working mostly in Iraq
in the last ten years on and off I mean
I didn't live there was through visits
but most of my work was there I've also
done work in Yemen and in Bahrain in the
last few years so based on that those
experiences I want to now give you a
overview of the phenomenon of
sectarianism and try to explain how not
how it occurred because it has been
there all along but how it was
accelerated in the last well in the last
two years for sure but even before since
I would argue since the Iranian
Revolution and to maybe suggest some
ways of you know trying to overcome it
or at least remove its worst aspects
it's important to define sectarianism I
offer the definition that it is a form
of bigotry bigotry that involves the
accentuation and manipulation of
religious difference for political ends
religious difference usually between
denominations of the same larger
religion so within Islam would be
between for example Sunni and Shiah
within Christianity between Catholics
and Protestants or any other sections of
these religions
so if we accept that definition the
question is how can say how is
sectarianism successful and can it be
prevalent at times because religious
difference is there all along whenever a
group splits off from a dominant group
you end up with difference between these
groups but that doesn't necessarily lead
to open conflict so when does that
happen and why and I would argue that
this is particularly likely in times of
great insecurity of armed conflict
violence chaos collapse of state
institutions great uncertainty to people
who seek recourse in sub-national
identities identities below that
presented by the state apparatus in the
absence of that state apparatus sub
identities that provide some kind of
protection because they are championed
by political actors that have the
resources to provide protection it's
like the Mafia but it's not necessarily
a bad actor can be a good actor it can
be an actor that seeks to protect the
group but by protecting it or by seeking
to protect it it also accentuates these
this identity specific identity which is
usually an identity opposed to another
one now I would argue that in the modern
Middle East sectarianism even though it
has existed all along because religious
difference has existed and it has been
manipulated in the past the upsurge
we've seen is a fairly recent phenomenon
and I go back again to the Iranian
Revolution the Iranian revolutions when
it started but I would say that the Arab
Awakening also called the Arab Spring
really brought it out because what the
Arab Spring did was to through popular
protest and popular mobilization
the action is to remove these state
structures in a number of countries but
we'll come back to that in a minute when
he say state structures had had
prevented the states depending on which
one you can look at different ones they
either used sectarianism politically for
their own ends but they managed to
contain the fallout from this because
they actually had a functioning state
structure but otherwise they managed too
hot to keep sectarianism at bay
essentially because groups in the end
their contests internal contests were
arbitrated and mediated by the state
structures so they were not allowed to
erupt in full but when you remove the
state structure you know all hell breaks
loose basically you know you take the
the lid of the pressure cooker and all
these countervailing claims come to the
fore and that's when sectarianism and
not only sectarianism it also ethnic
difference and other differences
political of course also come to the
fore with everybody claiming space and
seeking to to gain control to certainly
to reassert control over their own fate
or own lives livelihoods but also to
gain power now in more in Islam the main
sectarian difference or the main will I
say religious difference I should say is
it's between Sunni and Shia there is no
significant doctrinal difference between
Sunni and Shia they're both Muslims they
both these mainstream Sunni and the
mainstream Shia considered themselves
each other sorry as legitimate Muslims
they do not question the Islam of their
core religious coalition nests you know
she will go to Mecca to pray at the
shrine there as if they were Sunnis
they're not so nice but they are Muslims
and that's acceptable to them and
acceptable to the Sunnah I think it's
less common for Sunnis to go to Shia
mosques to pray there but it's
absolutely legitimate and and and it is
done and to the extent that people
intermarried and the the to section
sects I'm a mixed you will often see
across you know religiosity with people
going to each other's mosques very
common in cities in urban settings these
these doctrinal differences are further
overcome precisely because of what I
said the the intermarriage question
which in say Baghdad the Iraqi capital
is and has been very prominent but also
related to that the secularization that
occurs in urban settings so again the
whatever sectarian differences or really
sorry again religious different I have
to be careful with my term and I keep
tripping over them but religious
differences are easily overcome when the
society becomes more secular no I'm
going to tell you three anecdotes
throughout this presentation here's the
first one they're all three Ali versus
Omar stories and the first one will be
in Bahrain but before I do that Ali and
Omar these are names you know redolent
with meaning in the Islamic world why
because the origin of the split between
Sunni and Shia is not about religion but
about who is going to was going to
succeed the Prophet Muhammad and that
conflict was settled in favor of the
Sunni who designated one of the
compatriots of the of the Prophet as the
first caliph that was Abu Bakr and then
the second one was Omar the fourth one
was Ali Ali was the son-in-law of the
Prophet he claimed that the rightful
heir of the Prophet should be one of his
relatives in fact should be him there
was no agreement on this issue and the
two sides split off with Ali creating a
series of Amari becoming the the Imam of
his line of Islam with eleven to follow
the 12th one of which ended up
disappearing and being like the Messiah
supposedly coming back one day
and the the Sunni side had a series of
caliphs which eventually ended but until
now Sunni Islam is the mainstream form
of Islam and they're still talk of a
return to the caliphate
now Ali no margin behind so to - Shia
Ali is everything and to Sunnis Oh mark
among others is everything and these
names start also getting special
meanings when a situation religious
difference is sectarian eyes when it's
manipulated so in Bahrain for example a
year ago when I was there the I heard
from a colleague whom I met that one of
the big stories was that there was an
uproar at the local school and for young
children where a four year old boy named
Omar had been asked or forced by his
teacher a Shia to kiss her feet which is
a sign of deference but it goes a little
bit too far you might kiss a hand but
you would not kiss if a person's feet so
it's clearly the case of humiliation if
it occurred and the school launched a
little investigation but somehow the
news got out and through social media
before we knew it was a huge stink about
this alleged event with the the teacher
being threatened and the names of the
teacher and her husband being posted on
Twitter etc etc shortly after that
within a few days another story emerged
of a boy called Ali a Shia boy who was
16 and who had been arrested by the
security services and allegedly tortured
as part of an attempt to bring him to to
become a new former the boy was released
his parents went with him to the police
to lodge a complaint and instead of
accepting the complaint the police
accused him of of lying and and soon the
news was again all over through the
newspapers and me and the television
with a story of that this boy was
trying to frame the police and that the
Shia were making a lot of political hay
out of this case you know alleging
torture in order to cover up what had
happened to the little boy Omar in the
other case so the two stories became
intertwined well after a while it died
down and everybody went back to work and
everything was okay again the
interesting thing maybe first of all
that it occurred secondly that it was a
very common occurrence these stories are
happening all the time in behind today
and 30 that is that the person who told
me was also called Omar but he wasn't a
Sunni he was a Shia which just goes to
show that these names are actually
meaningless you know their Islamic names
but they don't actually indicate what a
person is plus he was totally secular he
would never in he would never call
himself a Shia or Sunni for that matter
it was irrelevant to him and in fact it
was wrong it was abhorrent to him anyway
so that's my little anecdote we'll come
back to other any dose later and
hopefully they will help elucidate the
larger point well the point is in part
that people in the Middle East as
anywhere in the world are walking
mosaics every person in him or herself
integrates a lot of different of blood
different blood and different beliefs
and different affinities they are
essentially very complex constructs if
you care to look closely enough so I can
say I'm Dutch but and my family has been
in the Netherlands for generations
that's true but you dig a little bit
deeper it turns out it actually I'm of
German stock it's not too hard to find
my last name is double n usually an
indicator anyway the Dutch could have
dropped in any you would have not known
it doesn't matter and if you start
digging deeper you'll find other things
and you find that societies are in fact
very heterogeneous and that with
population movements over the centuries
people have become totally blended and
mixed and so all of these denominations
are Sunni or Shia or Christian or this
or that
our artificial constructs in a way back
to the Middle East so what has brought
out the sectarianism that we see now is
a series of events a series of catalysts
and the first one the main one I would
argue was the Iranian Revolution in 1979
I will list the four and then go back to
them the next one was the uprising in
southern Iraq in 1991 following the
expulsion of Iraqi troops from Kuwait
which they had occupied for a number of
months the third one was the American
invasion of Iraq and then what that
brought in its wake and the fourth one
was the Arab Awakening so back to the
Iranian Revolution now this was a
revolution in the sense that it brought
to power a new regime that advocated a
form of Shiism that postulates that the
rulers should be the clerics in a Shia
Society its Elohim a company was it was
there was the leader and as the
revolution succeeded and brought this
new regime to power there wasn't
aspiration to carry out to carry forth
the revolution to other Shia populations
outside of Iran and the main sphere
populations are in Iraq which is a
majority Shia population in Lebanon
which is a way to see our plurality
sorry we know no census behind where
they are the majority of the citizens
but not a majority of the population why
is that well because the Bahraini Sunnis
have where the regime have imported a
lot of Sunnis from other countries from
Syria Jordan Pakistan and elsewhere non
Arabs also Pakistan else were too into a
behind to work they have not given him
citizenship in most cases but it was
clearly done as a country as a
counterweight to this year in Kuwait you
have a
simple Shia minority and in Saudi Arabia
you have a small Shia minority but that
minorities congregated on the on the
Gulf Coast and it so happens in the
areas of whether older Saudi Arabian oil
is so in a very critical strategic area
so the aspiration was there to carry
forth the revolution but it failed the
Shia revolution was not successful in
these other places it did not take off
and the reason I would argue is is that
for these people they did not subscribe
there were not Persians they were Arabs
and they I'm sorry about that she was
doing that off they did not subscribe to
sorry we're not Persians and secondly
they did not subscribe to the the new
ideology of the Iranian regime which was
the variety luckily the rule of the
jurisprudent the political leadership of
the clerics in in shia countries so it
didn't ignite but it what it did do this
iranian revolution is to trigger a
response from the Sunni side and a
radical response in the sense that
certain groups became radicalized in in
reaction and the Salafi group which is a
group or it's not a group but a
community of believers in a way a
subsection of the Sunni estonia's LOM
who they hark back to the original texts
so like a bit like Antonin Scalia le in
the American Constitution their original
lists and they so he go back to to the
Quran the way it was written and they
want to apply the the sayings of the
Prophet the way he supposedly meant them
at the time of course it's all a matter
of interpretation but they don't accept
that particular claim and the Salafis
have been around for a century or so but
after the Iranian Revolution they got a
lot of impetus from that and they
started organizing and luckily for them
the Soviets invaded Afghanistan they
went there they started fighting
they were very successful they received
American funding Osama bin Laden was
particularly you know prominent there
and they got a second when they went
back to their countries of origin and
began organizing there and until today
the phenomenon of Salafi jihadi ISM is
very very very land very strong and and
that's it that's that started all in
that period before we get to the next
catalyst we had the iran-iraq war the
war an eight-year war between Iran and
Iraq which was in a rock an attempt by
Saddam Hussein to dam in the Iranian
Revolution because of his fear that his
own Shia population would rise up
against him there was a majority Shia
population and there were certainly real
fears there again even though even
though there was no real evidence that
she I were about to rise up but they had
claims they had felt discriminated
against they had grievances and so in
fact nobody was happy on the side I was
saying but certainly the Shia or the
Shia Islamists in particular we're very
unhappy so there was reason to worry and
the war the Iraqi war effort was
supported by the Arab regimes Saudi
Arabia especially in the Gulf states
which were flush with oil money they you
know a paid paid a rocky war effort and
it became in effect a war between the
Shia Persians and the Arabs Sunnis and
so ethnic / sectarian conflict between
between these two states and their
majority populations and the interesting
thing is probably is that it remained a
conflict between two states and and it
did not become a shia-sunni conflict
because the shear of Iraq for example
during the iran-iraq war stayed loyal to
the regime and to Iraq I should say
maybe not to the regime to Iraq and they
thought they you know violently on the
Iraqi side in the war it's important to
remember in their in a sense their
ethnic as affinity as Arab as
prevailed over any religious affinity
they might have felt a Shia the next
catalyst or the second catalyst was the
southern uprising in Iraq in 1991 what
happened there was that after the defeat
in Kuwait Iraqi troops returned to Iraq
and very angrily you know burned
portraits of Saddam Hussein and revolted
against this regime these soldiers were
Sunni Shia Christian anything it was not
a Shia revolt but the population in
southern Iraq is majority Shia and so by
default I would say by by physical
presence in the South that revolt became
more Shia tyst maybe is the word but
what added to it was that the a Shia
opposition group Shia Islamist
opposition group based in Tehran been
being an Iranian proxy entered was
allowed to and was pushed to enter Iraq
in the south ambassador and tried to
take over the revolt to lead it and they
carried posters of their leader mohammad
baqir Hakeem
as well as well as Ayatollah Khomeini of
Iran and other Shia luminaries and this
then allowed the Iraqi regime to fight
back
maybe with American help because the
Americans then decided to allow the
Iraqis to fly helicopters which allowed
them to crush the revolt and I think the
fear was that the Iranians were going to
bring the Iraqi regime to a fall having
failed to do so during the iran-iraq war
and that this was not certainly not to
me rocky interest and also not a Western
interest okay now we come to the two
2003 in the American invasion of Iraq I
would argue that it accelerated the
sectarianism that already existed in
Iraq at the time the Saddam Hussein had
used as I said before States sometimes
use sectarianism but had contained it
Saddam Hussein had used it
he had oppressed certain groups in
society maybe a little bit more than he
oppressed everybody because he did
oppress everybody and in many ways
Saddam Hussein and his regime were
colorblind you know some of his main
henchman Russia for example he had Kurds
also in high ranks in his Christian it
was a Christian foreign minister because
Christians were no threat to him but but
he also targeted Kurds and the Shia when
these groups started pressing their
claims which they did in during the
iran-iraq war because they had the
opportunity to do it and by siding with
the Iranian enemy so the sectarianism
was there also it existed in the Iraqi
opposition which was based in Washington
and in London and in other Western
capitals this opposition was made up of
Shia Islamists and Kurdish groups just a
couple of Sunnis and some secular people
and the the position of the opposition
to the extent that they had a unified
position was that Iraq should be become
a federal state once saddam hussein was
gone and that there should be three
regions sunni region a shia region and
the kurdish region well that's a very
sectarian idea and so the opposition in
exile I should say not the internal
opposition held this view and was very
sectarian in its outlook but I would say
that with the US invasion the United
States became an agent of sectarianism
in Iraq in two ways one by creating a
system of government that was based on
what is called an Arabic mahasin which
is essentially the allotment of
political positions by the presumed size
of one's community be it again a
religious community or an ethnic
community or some other group that was
one way and the second way by organizing
free elections which it's hard to argue
with as a principle but which in a Shia
dirty country was going to lead to the
rise of the Shia into power and this was
the first time in modern history where
the Shia would and in fact eventually
did come to power in any of the
countries in which they are present so
it was a major a major event the 2005
elections January 2005 brought the Shia
to power and the interesting thing about
these elections and any subsequent
elections in Iraq until this day is that
all of the political parties almost to a
fault do not represent political ideas
but represent communities so they have
absorbed the sectarian notion because
all these parties were the former
opposition parties in exile except for
one but even that one is a sectarian
group we'll come back to that one in a
second so these political parties
represent communities and they you know
have they adhere to sort of the what I
call an either/or identity you know
you're either this or you're that but
there is no in-between and there is no
sort of taking a distance from that you
know no secular nonsense and they
engaged in zero-sum politics
so either we you know we we are in power
and you're not or you are in power and
we're screwed so we have to be in power
and the only way that we can stay in
power is to make sure that you never
have a chance to come to power that is
until this day in Iraq
the case was despite ease even as they
go through the exercise of Elections now
the sectarianism in Iraq had several
aspects that are important one is that
there was a an attempt at transitional
justice but it became also a sectarian
tool in two ways one there was an
attempt to to - well there was not an
attempt the bath party was banned and
former members were judged on the basis
of the positions they had taken in the
bath party no
necessarily on their behavior during the
regime but on their titles and ranks
which was not a very good indicator of
whether they were criminals for example
but that was done and this was a process
called de-baathification much much like
the Nazi vacation after the Second World
War in Germany and the second form and
this and this was done selectively
especially later on when those by the
new order elected order those who were
Sunnis were more likely to be banned and
to be prevented from taking jobs then
the Shia who were slowly gradually
integrated into the new order maybe not
to the top positions but all the same -
but be allowed to to be there and
sometimes actually quite some prominent
positions in where for example the legal
advisor to Prime Minister Maliki today
was also the legal adviser to Saddam
Hussein these things happen and the
second way other than the bifurcation
was through the tribunal the Iraq
tribunal which became an instrument of
Victor's justice and if you remember the
scenes of the lynching of Saddam Hussein
this was very much interpreted in
sectarian ways as the Shia lynching a
Sunni rather than sort of a popular
group lynching still lynching a dictator
so all of these things became meaningful
in a sectarian terms
another aspect was of course the
violence and the anti-shiite animus that
existed and if you looked at the
websites and and the rhetoric and the
sermons in the mosques you would hear on
the Sunni side the reference to the Shia
as aphid the rejectionists the people
who reject what to reject the line of
the Prophet that the Sunnis had
established again it's the dynastic
struggle to succession issue and they
refer to them as Persians ferrocene or
sovereign Safavids
so this
and this was a literal epithets it was
clearly these were ways of denigrating
the the opponent from the other side the
Shia also had some choice language for
Sunnis and and became a very you know
negative dynamic and the result was
violence the violence came originally
from this from one group al Qaeda al
Qaeda in Iraq and it targeted very
clearly the Shia they one of their
favorite targets was sort of these these
population groups that are very
vulnerable like pilgrims you know going
to Karbala or going to a certain shrine
maybe a bit like the most Boston
Marathon you know it's very easy to
target large groups of people it's very
difficult to protect these groups of
people so and they they went after it
with a vengeance they also set off bombs
and marketplaces in buses that in Shia
neighborhoods etc etc and so it it and
then that that was what initiated it and
then it became a cycle once after the
2005 elections when the Shia Islamist
parties to control over the levers of
the state and the instruments of
violence and were able to deploy police
in the army against Sunni neighborhoods
and it became equally indiscriminate
and we had a sectarian war now you ask
Sunni Shia you know they're fighting
each other how did they know who was who
and that is a very good question and I
cannot answer it
and as I said earlier you know there was
a Shia Omar and so names or appearance
or place of residence are not very
accurate indicators in fact they're
terrible indicators but they're never
stopped anyone in a sectarian conflict
believe me and you've seen in the
Balkans the same and any of these
conflicts you see that it doesn't matter
and of course it is it's a it's a
terrible thing in families where you
have heavy intermarriage because then
you're actually fighting your spouse or
you know your uncle or this or that and
and what we saw in Iraq is actually the
breakdown of families in in Baghdad
especially as a result of the
sectarian war that was happening I'll
tell you the second anecdote about a
lien Omar I was living in Jordan at the
time this was in 2005 or so 2006 and a
lot of refugees were coming from Iraq
into Jordan and the a couple of them
came to our office and they working for
human rights organizations and they they
wanted to tell their story and so the
first guy one of the guys was his name
was OMA and he was telling me and he was
really outraged this is when he came in
to Jordan through the airport the
Jordanian intelligence there asked him
if he was Sunni or Shia and they said
you know your name is Omar and and but
it not much happened because they the
trains already assumed he was a Sunni
and so they let him in but he was
actually a Shia he was a Shia called
Omar and he really resented the fact
that he was asked a question of course
he didn't say anything so he got into
Jordan all right as a refugee his
colleague was named Ali and you already
guessed that he is a Sunni and so he got
in despite his name for two reasons
probably one is because maybe from his
family name the Jordanians who know the
tribal system in Iraq quite well figured
out that he was a Sunni or because Ali
is actually very common name in Jordan
in fact members of the royal family are
called Ali and Ali is it's no longer a
Shia name basically so again it's a very
poor marker of of your background anyway
so both ended up in Jordan but the fact
the issue is of course that the
Jordanians were explicitly asking
refugees whether they were Sunni or Shia
which is not a helpful thing when you're
worried when when was a conflict because
it escalates the conflict all right
the the collapse of Iraq which happened
after 2003 led to the fragmentation of
the National Iraqi identity and gave
rise or gave impetus to a number of the
sub-national identities like Shi ISM and
soon ISM and Kurds as an
the group and then Assyrians and the
Chaldeans and Yazidis and the Armenians
and the dis and the dot and everybody
suddenly was politically active they had
political parties you only needed three
people or whatever to have a political
party you know the Christians are a very
small group in Iraq but that never
prevented them from having a lot of
political parties the turkmens the same
and so and each wanting to be at the
table to be represented as a community
and always downplaying their their the
people closest to them but slightly
different and one of the political
schemes that came out of this or the
ideas in fact I can't say cooked up in
the United States because it wasn't but
something that certainly some of the
politicians here latched onto but it
came out of the Iraqi opposition was
this notion of partition partition in
Iraq and having these three regions
Sunni Shia and Kurd and you know it had
some traction for a while not in Iraq by
the way except among the Kurds who very
much liked it and among one of the Shia
Islamist parties and but you know if any
attempt had been made in that direction
I the violence would have escalated
enormous ly because of the population
displacement that partition usually
brings look at India Pakistan and it
would have replaced a very difficult but
necessary debate over democracy how do
you and pluralism how do you make
communities live together in a within
certain boundaries I would replace that
debate with a debate over boundaries
because once you establish regions you
have to establish the boundaries between
them and believe me nobody ever agrees
or where the boundary should be
especially when you start looking at
Iraq where there's resources in the
ground oil and of course everybody wants
to maximize their territory and they
come up with all kinds of arguments why
that area really belongs to them so you
don't actually mitigate conflict by
these schemes but you might
change the nature of the conflict and
you may even make it worse now that said
there was also pushed back in Iraq
against against sectarianism and that
that is very important and I can say
gave a couple of examples one was in
2004 when one of the leaders only the
leader of sorry of one of these Shia
Islamist groups the thus address'd
movement mocked at asada reached out his
XI Scioscia he reached out to the Sunnis
in one province unbar and expressed sort
of solidarity going back to the notion
of there is an Iraq out there it didn't
last very long because in the end
everybody nobody's fooled the man is a
sectarian Shia
and in his usual rhetoric that's very
clear but he felt it necessary to reach
across the aisle if you were if you will
in order to increase his political
standing and influence in Iraq and rise
to to leadership so the attempt failed
but it's interesting that he tried it
and he's made several subsequent
attempts as well and the second example
is from the political party that once
wanted to establish a Shia region the
Islamic Council for the sorry the
Islamic Council for the revolution in
Iraq or whatever Supreme Council for the
Islamic Revolution in Iraq sorry it's
now changed his name they in the 2009
provincial elections realizing that they
had lost a lot of ground in Iraq because
of the sectarianism and their poor
governance started to lower their
sectarian rhetoric and started you know
emphasizing again sort of the
nationalism of Iraqis but it was too
late for them they the damage had been
done and they lost miserably in those
elections but it was also because the
people in Iraq were coming out very
clearly and this was very clear in the
interviews we did with people in the
provinces very clearly against
sectarianism then they wanted no truck
with it alright the final catalyst and
I'm going slow here I should be
speeding up was the the Arab Awakening
now this was a pro-democracy movement in
various countries that was eventually in
some countries subverted by those in
power by using the sectarian threat and
especially sectarian slash the Iran
Threat so the the issue is here that
while there is only a small Sunni
minority in in Iran the Arab world has a
fairly significant Shia minority and
again I said II Rockets a majority in in
Bahrain as well so it is a significant
minority and this minority has at times
been seen as a fifth column as
essentially a foreign agent allied with
Iran and so what happened during the
Arab Awakening is that some of the Sunni
regimes especially Saudi Arabia and
others started to present or to
represent an internal threat to their
rule a popular threat as an external
threat meaning Iran so these internal
people are not really calling for
democracy they are trying to bring Iran
here with its leadership of the of the
jurisprudence so you know Xie rule
basically they're trying to replace us
our regimes and this was a way to appeal
to the majority Sunni public to get them
to separate themselves or those among
them who were pro-democracy to separate
themselves from the Shia this worked
very well in behind the first instance
people had gathered at the beginning of
the Arab Spring Arab Awakening Iran
around the Pearl Monument in Pearl
Square which was a national monument
because pearl fishing was used to do and
so it was an a potent symbol of
nationalism and people came there to
protest against the regime making clear
we are behinds we are against this
regime
we want to reform it maybe some of us
want to overthrow it but in any case
that it's a political issue soon the
regime managed to separate the Sunni
element most of it anyway in the protest
in the protesters away from from from
from the from the Pearl Square and move
them to another place called Fatih
mosque no factor most fat that means the
conqueror it could be the Prophet but in
this case it was the Khalifa family who
had conquered the island three centuries
ago and had named this mosque after them
and so suddenly the conflict took on a
sectarian overtone and and and the
protesters were crushed
there was a Saudi and two very military
intervention the and the Bahraini police
then crack down on the on the protesters
and then only then suddenly you heard
this about the Iran Threat and suddenly
after a month the protesters were called
Iranian agents the junior protesters
never came up so it was clearly
manipulated what has happened in the
region is that Saudi Arabia has ignited
a new out of fear of what happened in
Egypt and that it might happen in Saudi
Arabia and starting in behind
it's a Achilles heel Saudi Arabia
ignited a new round in what has been a
cold war between Iran and Saudi Arabia
since the Iranian Revolution
using religious difference as a foreign
policy tool it's part of a balance of
power game now what's at stake the stake
is the loyalty of the defense citrus or
the weak the weak in between so behind
was one of them and their Saudi Arabia
succeeded the loyalty of behind was
secured the Shia were put back in the
box for now not very well by the way but
the argument that that behind Shia were
foreign agents or Iran in ages is a
strange one because if you look at
neighboring Kuwait the minority share
there are actually provision they are
not pro Iran and so they couldn't be
possibly accused of being Pro Iran it's
just that the Power Balance is different
in Kuwait so this Shia who are not very
different from the Shia in Bahrain or
Saudi Arabia are there pro-regime
and so everybody's sunni regime when
everybody's happened so the argument is
clearly the logic is lacking but it's
still as a as a rhetorical argument it
resonates with the public the loyalty of
behind the loyalty of Hamas as a
Palestinian resistance movement
it's a Sunni movement it's a branch if
such exists of the Muslim Brotherhood in
before the Arab Awakening Hamas was
receiving Iranian funding it was quite
open about it it doesn't mean that it
was pro-iranian it said took the money
said thank you very much
we can use that and the Iranians of
course have their own thoughts about it
it got so bad that Fatah the more
secular Palestinian movement of Yasser
Arafat started referring to Hamas a Shia
which of course they're not theirs
they're Sony but they're very Sony in
fact but you know it was it was a was a
way of attacking them rhetorically so
and another example of Hamas in Jordan
in 2005 just ahead of the Iraqi
elections that brought the Shia to power
the king was talking about a Shia
Crescent trusted throughout the region
and people were thinking she a crescent
okay well Iraq maybe does she maybe some
other places but what is he talking
about what he was talking about was
Jordan but I don't know she I enjoyed it
maybe one or two some refugees for sure
from the Saddam era but there were no
Shia but what he was referring to was
actually the Muslim Brotherhood who are
Sunni but who were his internal threat
but he was because they were taking
Iranian money he was associating them
with the Shia threat was the Iran Threat
and again there's a conflation of Shia
with Iran Mubarak Hosni Mubarak the
dictator autocrat of Egypt actually said
that the Shia in their world are Iranian
proxies he said very explicitly at the
same time in 2004 late 2004 alright so
but Hamas in the Arab Awakening its
loyalty was lost to the to Iran and it
was gained by the Sunnis because Hamas
seeing the way things were going
decided to go with the Muslim
Brotherhood and because the Muslim
Brotherhood came to power in Egypt in
Tunisia in Libya even in Morocco very
strong in Yemen making progress and so
Hamas figured out that the wave of the
future is to go along with our brethren
literally and and so they they cut their
ties with Iran and they moved their
headquarters from Damascus elsewhere ok
so at the moment we have a regional
perception I would say of of two
regional sectarian alliances emerging
between Saudi Arabia and its allies and
Iran and its allies and the next loyalty
test will be and it's already happening
is Syria Syria is now the battleground
and it's a place where you have a
majority Sunni population but it's a
mosaic a series a mosaic ters like Iraq
is a mosaic but there's a minority
regime who are a low whites who are
self-described Shia but they're not
there they're sort of a distinct group
of Shia that have some heterodox
practices like they follow some
Christian holidays and some of them seem
to believe in reincarnation which
doesn't put them sort of outside of
Islam altogether
so as though the Christian practices so
there they are not very comfortable Shia
let's say no matter in this kind of
conflict things are black and white and
so now they are seen as Sunnis in a lot
of the rhetoric especially rhetoric
coming from outside Syria where these
distinctions fade so in Saudi Arabia for
example so they're called Shia and
vice-versa a mirror image the the the
Alouettes are being supported in the
Shia world as Shia and so you see these
this emergence of these this regional or
the perception of regional alliances
Arab Sunni versus Persian Shia but just
during a roni Rock War we had this now
the battleground of Syria and it will
again be Iraq and Lebanon after after
the situation in Syria settled or maybe
even before that and what the people but
the Iraqi Sunnis and Iraqi Shia are
doing in this battle is to seek
strategic depth so the Sunni in Iraq
are one thing Syria to be on their side
the new Syria the new Sunni majority
Sunni dominated Syria the Shia of Iraq
are seeking help from Iran there are not
natural allies of Iran but when they are
threatened
Iran is their place of last resort and
so and their area of strategic depth so
that's that's where we are today now
finally a couple of questions I want to
dispose and maybe provide some answers
to how does sectarianism succeed again
in a situation of insecurity need for
protection ability for political groups
to manipulate and to mobilize in in a
situation of violence and insecurity
sectarianism is fueled but vice-versa
when there are sectarianism that in
itself fuels the violence and so it's a
vicious cycle and a opposite to that you
have also diverted the other cycle the
virtuous cycle is that you know how can
you get sectarianism to fade or to
become more latent again through having
peace and security which dampen
sectarianism but sectarian but but at
the same time if sectarianism goes down
that also encourages more peaceful
solutions to existing conflicts and so
you have a virtuous circle the question
is how do you get from the vicious
circle to the virtuous circle or how can
you prevent the vicious circle in the in
the first place I go back to the the
example of the 2009 elections in Iraq
where the people were exhausted by the
sectarian conflict and exasperated by
the sectarian parties and their rhetoric
because they realized that that
sectarian politics only brought them
grief and further violence and further
instability and insecurity and so
eventually it is a combination of these
factors that will exhaust the the
vicious cycle and can lead to a virtuous
one but there's a larger question of how
can you put the genie back into the
bottle and I don't have any easy
solutions but there are some conditions
that would have to be met
one of them is you need to have a stable
and inclusive transition in Syria
political transition in Syria good luck
secondly you need to have a regional
security framework but everybody at the
table this was discussed some time ago
not recently and again good luck it's
not going to happen anytime soon you
need to have an active discouragement of
what you would call here hate speech of
sectarian rhetoric especially in the
official media where would impetus come
from unclear but that's what would
that's a condition there would have to
be stepping up of and promotion of
exchanges be it trade very important be
it
tourism religious tourism pilgrimages
because especially she but others also
and you know go to other shrines and
studies students and maybe other other
dimensions that you can think of and I
would say for the United States it has
to would have to be you know act very
and the Western world generally but the
u.s. is particularly prominent in these
in this area I'd say to tread very
carefully when and to understand these
the sectarianism that exists and to be
sensitive to religious differences
between groups to understand that not
all Salafis for example are violent many
are not
and that Salafis are different from the
muslim brotherhood and that the modern
muslim brotherhood is also not
homogeneous and there are many different
factions you know and that the vast vast
majority of muslims are supporting
political processes these are very
important things so that kind of
awareness has to exist
and i would also say the united states
would have to do more to lean on the
Saudi Arabia to and the Gulf states its
allies to bring the Syrian conflict to a
political conclusion and that again is
that has a transition that is inclusive
and pluralist I leave it at that
except for one more little anecdote of
an ally and Omar a friend of mine in
Iraq his name is Samir
and he lived on a Saddam Hussein he was
working for a company his first son he
named Ali so his company with mostly
Sunnis turned out where he says and so
when he named his son Ali people were
disappointed now in Iraq or in many Arab
countries
you name your book you have your own
name but then you become known after the
birth of your first son or something
even before that by that name so you
become Abu Ali you know father of Ali so
he to his family and to his people
around him became Abu Ali but that
worked they refused to call him Abu Ali
and I kept calling him some year hey
then he had a daughter and then he had
another son and that son now he became
smart he called him Omar
and so people at work I mean he said Oh
Omar I'm so happy for you my book no
regulations of course you know he was
not Abu Omar
it was Abu Ali but they called him I
worked with them he was Abu Omar
so all fine and good he survived the
Saddam era and today they're living in a
Shia regime essentially and suddenly his
son son amar has the wrong name so now
each time he needs to get anything done
to get a job or to get a permit or
something his father has to come along
and establish a Shia credentials
that's Iraq today thank you very much
but the last generally I'm interested to
know your thoughts about how the Iraqi
spring has been different from the other
movements around the region particularly
when we look at the difference between
the protests in Iraq from 2011 to the
ones that are much more sectarian now do
you think that that reflects factors
from abroad or are these really domestic
concerns okay
as I said they'll take three questions
and I'll come back to you the Gulf War
of each month okay transpires a result
of which was a lot of okay I thought it
was a third one
mostly yes sir to what extent do you
think the current cue Isis Russian
okay okay well I'll take him in order I
think that's fine so you know the the
Arab Awakening Arab Spring did not
really happen in Iraq except in Iraqi
Kurdistan and the thing is you know the
it broke out in in January 2011 which
was one month after Maliki was
reappointed as prime minister following
elections that were generally free and
fair so Maliki said hey guys I am NOT
the enemy
I'm not an autocrat I'm not like Mubarak
I'm not like Xena didn't burn Ali I am a
democratically elected leader I've been
an office for one month not 30 years so
give me a chance
so the give me a hundred days he said of
course after hundred days nothing had
changed but he has a problem but
at that time he got away with that and
so there were not many protests there
were so many protests over the lack of
electricity which has been in a light
motif since 2003 but by and large he
didn't see in Iraq the kinds of protests
that he saw in other parts of the Arab
world and I saw it was it was entirely
domestic but Maliki has a problem which
is he is an autocrat re or he wants to
be one maybe or he is being led to be
one I have to be very careful here
because it's not entirely clear yet and
maybe we need another few years to look
back and say this is what really
happened but he has a an autocratic
tendency or he's on an autocratic
tendency let's put it that way so and
and he is more and more relying on his
party the Dawa party which is a Shia
Islam is party which is not entirely
stranger to sectarianism - to promote
his power base and and so others respond
to it in a sectarian way and so the
protest more recently have been over the
power struggle but it has again at stake
in a sectarian overtone so now the
protests are in Sunni provinces mostly
but so it is actually a separate
development from the it's more based on
the Iraqi history which I also outline
and not related to the Arab Awakening I
would say the Gulf War now I did I mean
I didn't say the Gulf War but I did talk
about the uprising southern Iraq which
came out of the expulsion from the
expulsion of the Iraqi troops from
Kuwait so that was a direct outcome of
the Gulf War so in terms of the Gulf War
and sectarianism you know the Iraqi
invasion of Kuwait was not in itself a
sectarian issue has not been sectarian
eyes it was basically an attempt to to
shake you know shake down the the
bankers and the and and the result was
the defeat of Iraq in Kuwait the
restoration of the Kuwaiti regime but
the uprisings in Iraq which were - one
in the south and I mentioned and the
north the Kurds
so in that sense the country started to
take a little bit the form of that
tripartite division that I mentioned was
especially with the establishment of the
no-fly zones so the Kurds in the north
the Shia and the South but you know you
have to be careful with these things and
earlier when I mentioned these three
regions Sunnis Shia and Kurds people
sort of they take a map and they say
okay that's Kurds the middle it's the
Sunnis and the South is a shear but it's
an it's idiotic idea in Iraq because if
you just put a line like that north
well Mosul is an Arab city you know I
have some Kurds that Christians turkmens
whatnot but it's an Arab city it's
clearly above the line if you look at
the no-fly zone sulemani a Kurdish City
was the south of the no-fly zone don't
ask why
it's just because it was easy to say
no-fly zone 30:36 parallel or whatever
parallel it was you know these people
don't necessarily think about protecting
people the middle region of Iraq
includes Baghdad which is a majority
Shia City and has significant Shia
pockets north of it Samara
Norwell Samara has not many Shia now but
Harless and other towns are Shia and of
course has also Sunni population and
then and many secular and then the
southern part is a majority Shia
population but basa always had a
significant Sunni minority and if you go
from Basra to Kuwait it's mostly Sunni
plus the tribes to the to the west of
the Tigris and Euphrates are also a lot
of Sunnis there in fact all tribes in
Iraq and say I can probably say all
tribes in Iraq have both Sunni and Shia
elements there are no Shia tribes and
Sunni tribes so these are important
things anyway so I think I did mention
the Gulf War but maybe not by name yeah
tobacco bacteria yeah do
yeah Iranian encouraging to senator rock
right which was proceeded to go for the
Iranian no no no does the iran-iraq war
ended in 1988 in 1990 Iraq invaded
Kuwait in January 1991 the uprising
started when the troops returned and
then the Supreme Council was pushed
across the board happily went across the
border and tried to to take over the
uprising yeah okay good so the question
about Russia and the Cold War yeah it's
a very important one because I'm not
sure it's it it helps sustain
sectarianism in a way even though the
Russians don't care about Sunni and Shia
I think but it's it's it helps sustain
it simply because it helps sustain more
importantly the Syrian civil war because
when it comes to the alliances Russia
China Iran Iraq somehow are on one side
and they they say they accept a an
inclusive political process but for them
inclusive means including Bashar
al-assad the other side also sort of a
strange alliance turkey Saudi Arabia the
Gulf states and the United States and
the Western countries they also want to
say they want to increase the political
process but without Bashar al Assad I
think that is the breaking point and
nobody can agree and so by not agreeing
and by the fear that if they intervene
more directly at least for the United
States and Russia that they might get
into direct conflict I think they help
sustain the internal conflict and hope
to contain it and that may or may not
succeed the longer it lasts the less
likely that they will succeed I suppose
so and so and and because it is becoming
a sectarian or has become a sectarian
conflict then logically then also
sustaining that that sectarian nature
yes yes but I'm not sure that plays in
this case I'm not sure I'm not the
expert on this and I stand to be
corrected but I don't have the sense
that that is a factor I think for the
Russians the stake in Syria other than
sort of having some warships being able
to you know put anchor down is that you
know they don't want the United States
to succeed in Syria you know they're
still very angry about Libya and they
you know and they just don't want the
United States and the western states to
to determine if there's a new order in
the Middle East so so they're holding
out and they they want to have their
imprint on it but I think there is
there's room for common ground too
because you could give the Russians room
at the table a roll this and that I
think in the end the the killer is going
to be Iran Iran is not going to let that
happen
and the problem with Iran is that it's
not only conflict about Syria but it's
really a conflict about the nuclear
program and as we know that is pretty
much stuck so it's you know these things
are all linked somehow and not moving
forwards at least not in the right way
okay the question on the
israel-palestine conflict of course this
is like the primordial conflict in the
Middle East at least since 1948
now before and and so it has in a way
been overtaken by the sectarian conflict
and I'm sure that some are you know very
happy about this but it's it's pity and
it's a it's a tragedy really because
it's it's it doesn't do anything to to
resolve the Palestinian issue any time
soon
as I mentioned earlier there was a
sectarian dimension to the Hamas thing I
mean it's a bit of a joke because Hamas
clearly was not a Shia actor and it was
a tactical alliance with Iran for
political reasons you know Iran will
support anybody whether they're Shia or
not if that can advance its its
strategic goals in the region so Hamas
included and Hamas vice versa will take
support from I'm not sure from anyone
but certainly was willing to support to
receive Iranian support in order to
fight against Israel
so but so other than that there is no
sectarian issue there and now with the
Arab Awakening which bypassed Palestine
and Lebanon and Iraq now you know and
the conflict has been sectarian eyes by
the regimes that we're using this in
order to stay in power and all the
attention has been diverted from from
the israel-palestine conflict it remains
as unresolved so we now have all right
thank you thank you outlook on Egypt
mm-hmm say the next five years it's a
bit outside terms of this presentations
or sectarianism but it's not like well
there's a Coptic issue okay okay
comment on the recent area in Egypt
okay
the to the consumer mr. so it sounds
like southern and how you interpreted
his overtures to the Sunnis in Iraq as
as a ploy and leads but I wonder to what
extent it wasn't a glory and he was
actually tapping on into a sense that
there was no appetite for sectarianism
among the lorries the masses in Iraq and
there was a sense in which they would
assure international identity that
people and the enemy at that point was
the United States are not Syria and
there was basically four common struggle
it sounds like for a petition that this
many different conflicts in the
different countries that you describe
they have economic or other bases
okay thanks okay all right got a bunch
yeah do not around okay in western
economic and military interests well you
know if people want to fight they'll
fight you know they'll go fisticuffs in
the hallway you know you don't need
weapons
but weapons you know make it more easy
to the resort to weapons you know it's
like the whole gun debate in this
country you know once you have access to
go to weapons you might be more likely
to resort to the violence to settle
conflicts the I'm not sure I don't know
if the answer is yes or no to your to
your question you know the Saudis it's
not like they don't have a military
apparatus they have a very strong
military presence but you don't have is
an industrial base you know the Saudis
buy everything you know they don't build
anything so obviously if they need
weapons they go to the United States to
buy them because they've got the money
whether that fuels sectarianism I don't
think so I mean it weapons may fuel
conflict to some extent in some areas
and so but the fact is that the conflict
must be pre-existing I don't think they
they cause conflict that's my view but
I'm sure others would disagree Egypt I
my outlook I'm not I'm not an expert on
Egypt so what I'm gonna say is is you
can take with a grain of salt basically
but you know Egypt is going through a
very important development the the
Muslim Brotherhood won the elections I
don't know if it's a majority based
regime but it certainly got me you know
the support it needed in order to form a
government that's important I think they
deserve a chance to prove themselves you
know people say that you know it's one
man one man woman one man one vote one
time you know that this is what the
Muslims wanted the Muslim Brotherhood
want is totally unfair because these are
the same people who for 30 years put up
with dictatorship or maybe didn't put up
with it but in any case you know the
Muslim Brotherhood suffered as much as
anybody else from the dictatorship they
should be given a chance to prove
themselves both in terms of their
democratic credentials and their
governance skills and it's really too
early it's a very unstable situation
still I think the Muslim Brotherhood
made or the new government has made some
mistakes with the Constitution other
things but the opposition has also made
mistakes and not wanting to engage in
dialogue and so you know the fault on
both sides and it's really too early but
five years down the line I assume that
this order will still be there in some
form I don't think people are ready to
throw out the Muslim brother famous last
words
I'm always terrible at predictions are
usually wrong so I'm better backward
I can handle better the so but the real
the real problem in Egypt of course is
economic challenges and so the fact is
is that the Muslim Brotherhood or
whatever government cannot deliver
anything because of the huge economic
challenges and the employment challenges
that that any regime any government
would face in Egypt so that that is an
inherently destabilizing factor in the
next five years and beyond
so so I don't expect any read anything
really stable to emerge anytime soon but
and you might have you know as we've
seen in other countries and other eras
you know you might see a second
revolution or a further correction or
you might see a counter-coup as well
you know with the military's if being
fed up and and trying to you know put
the lid back on somehow and just oppress
violently anyone who dares to to protest
and solve economic problems that way
just keep people down you know it's
worked for a long time could work again
so I don't know which way it will go as
for the cops you know that is you know
also very frightening of course that
there's the sectarian element there's
been you know a lot of violence against
cops a lot of kidnappings for ransom of
Coptic professionals inside in Cairo and
outside Cairo so you know but I don't
know how long that how durable that is
and I think I've heard some of the cops
saying it's because they're now living
under a Muslim or an Islamist regime I
think that's wrong there is no evidence
in history that the Muslims would be
violent against the Christians once
they're in power what I think is
happening is that it's in its a period
in which there is no stable government
that has effective control of the
security apparatus and so in that kind
of situation you see a lot of
criminality and you see also criminality
that may be targeting the vulnerable
populations which are inevitably
minorities so I think that that is what
is going on and so what you need never
mind who is in power in era in Egypt
where is the Muslim Brotherhood or a
secular party or this or that but the
fact that there is a stable regime and
that actually has control over the
levers of monopoly over the means of
violence if you want so that's my view
on this but anyway it is very unpleasant
what is happening now Mukhtar the
southern in 2004 of course Nicholas is
asking the most difficult question
because it's I'm not sure which way I
would go so I'm just going to
budget and say that all of what you said
is true and what I said also is that
mooks lettuce other did use a ploy in
order to distinguish himself from his
political rivals in the shia community
because his main rival at that time was
the supreme council and subsequently
became Maliki in the Dawa party but
their Shia Islamists like him and it's
not necessarily the Sunnis it's not the
Kurds he's also spoken against Sunnis
and against Kurtz but a tie at different
times but his main rivals for power are
the ones who are most likely to have
power and had power the Supreme Council
and our Maliki because Southern
eventually wants to be the one in power
and so he used it as a ploy but he also
knew very well that is a wellspring of
anti sectarianism in Iraq that
especially in turn in 2004 there was the
sectarian conflict and then it came back
and so he built on that I think plus he
could mobilize people across the aisle
fighting against the Americans because
that's something that most people agreed
with Sunni and Shia in Iraq because the
you know from the Sunni she would expect
it because they throughout the Shia so
now they're out of power and the America
they blame the Americans but even among
she and I was there even though it was
very obvious you know people were very
unhappy about what the United States had
brought yes the fall of the regime thank
you great
why didn't you leave or why did you not
fix the electricity you know they
thought that the Americans with their
power could just fix the electricity
instead what happened was the
electricity which was actually destroyed
by a decade of sanctions the Americans
couldn't fix it fix it plus the demands
shot up and so you had total collapse
and this is what got people really angry
plus the insecurity in the streets
because the Americans were actually
under deployed and so they could not you
know rain in the militias that were
running rampant and and so people were
very angry in fact and
a lot of people were just ready to fight
so for the southern it was a a a smart
thing to try but in the end you know
you're not gonna fool any Sony about
motor solar you know he is going to be
what he's doing everybody knew he was
doing it in order to gain power as a
Shia leader and and you know who cares
about the Sunnis in Anbar so that that's
my take on that
finally is it a US interests to to
promote it what was the code to promote
sectarianism in in the region or you
know is that the yea benefit net benefit
I think I could be wrong but I think the
United States has its strong interest
protecting Israel protecting the oil
flow at reasonable prices so these are
important things but otherwise it wants
to keep things in balance pretty much
because if you keep things in balance
they're predictable and you can plan you
can do this and that when you have
unpredictability you know everything is
up for grabs you don't know how you're
going to come out you know with the
winners or with the losers you know in
Egypt certainly that became an issue in
2011 so I think I think they don't have
an inherent interest in sectarianism in
the region to the extent that fuels
conflict which invariably does so I you
know I'm not going to say the United
States government is a good thing or a
bad thing I don't make that judgment
anyway but is is is is is is you know
they're on the right side and they want
to do the right thing in the middle east
and they're not promoting sectarianism I
think it's not in their interest to do
it and and so and I've seen no evidence
of it anyway
you know and in fact it's very important
example of this is in Bahrain you know
given the enmity between Iran in the
United States you would think the United
States would take any opportunity to say
you know the Iranians are behind this
but in Bahrain they have been
consistently saying since the beginning
of the uprising that there is not a
shred of evidence that the Iranians are
behind the uprising that is led by the
Shia and there's not a shred of evidence
that the Shia in Bahrain are being you
know driven by by by the Iranians
they've made very clear to the
contrary that by not opening up the
political system and allowing the Shia
more voice to enfranchise them they are
driving the Shia into Iranian arms so to
the em to the American government until
this day the Arab Shia of Bahrain and in
fact the Arab C of Iraq Maliki they
support them as a buffer against Iran
and they don't see him as a proxy of
Iran and I think that's correct I mean
that's a correct analysis and they are
on the right side of course it could
change if Maliki for example is out of
fear and are the further sectarianism
because of the Syria conflict is driven
into Iranian arms for protection then
I'm not sure of the United States would
still be selling the f-16s to him right
because then who's going to use them and
in Bahrain the same thing might happen
but I think in the Sunni orbit then it
sort of goes hand in hand but I think
without the political actors actively
manipulating and providing protection
people would not be taking any action on
a personal level against the neighbors
for example because they need a
protected environment in which to do it
in which they know they are the dominant
group and you saw in in the sectarian
war in Iraq from 2004-2005 until about
2008 what happened in neighborhoods
embark that now most me neighborhoods
and bar that are totally mixed you know
and sometimes people say well that's a
Sunni neighborhood that's a Shia
neighborhood well fine but I mean Sunni
majority neighborhood and Shia majority
neighborhood there's always other groups
in these neighborhoods there is no such
thing as a pure Sunni anyway because
people intermarried it's an insane
notion to begin with
so but you know you can have an area
around a certain Sunni mosque that is
more going to be more heavily Sunni I
accept that
and so the happens in every talk I give
at one point I lose my train of thought
so this moment has now arrived the what
were we talking about yeah the
personalization so the in the
neighborhoods what happened was is that
certain militias who were linked to
political parties that are Shiite
Islamist or Sunni some form that that
these that these parties would take
control over certain neighbors or
certain sections of neighborhoods and
then it's very interesting to see what
happened in those in those section in
those neighborhoods so if there was a
Shia militia controlling a certain
neighborhood it would expel Sunni young
men and maybe families and a lot of
families were displaced in this conflict
but it might also let people stay if
they were no longer a threat
so they controlled the neighborhood so
neighborhood so even after the conflict
there were a lot of neighborhoods that
had never ceased being mixed
neighborhoods so it's very interesting
thing so it's it's there are the
personalization is there but really the
key issue is is who who's in control and
you know what's their perspective and
what is their behavior toward the enemy
population I think